le dr karl weiss est avec nous bonsoir
dr weiss bonsoir patrice bon montréal on
dirait qu'on s'en sortira jamais là on
avait l'impression que alors que les
régions avance l'association de montréal
en fait sur place le nuage gris reste
sur montréal les morts s'accumulent et
on voit pas la courbe redescendre coma
où vous en êtes dans votre
interprétation de ce qui se passe mais
c'est clair que rial et je dirais même
la grande région de montréal y ait un
problème importante l'igname au québec
quand on regarde 911 nouveaux cas
imaginez si on x la population par
exemple aux états unis qui à peu près 40
fois la population du québec
donc ça voudrait dire quasiment 40
nouveaux quarante mille nouveaux cas
l'équivalent aux états unis donc c'est
clair que la majorité dans la région de
montréal donc ses pertes à moriat d une
épidémie qui est encore actif dynamique
rappelez vous quand il ya longtemps on
disait est ce qu'on a atteint le pic et
on disait ben peut-être que oui mais
qu'une fois qu'on a atteint un pic
on va rester longtemps sur le sommet et
ça va être un plateau qui va être long
avant de redescendre
donc il y avait pas un pic et là on est
probablement encore sur le plateau si ce
n'est pas encore tout à fait au sommet
sommet donc définitivement la région de
montréal est une région qui est
problématique en termes d'activité du
virus et on a plusieurs je vous dirais
on a plusieurs épidémies à l'intérieur
de mauriac
il ya bien sûr les ch et celle d il ya
aussi certaines régions montréal comme
l'est et le nord de montréal
il ya aussi des travailleurs de la santé
parce que souvent les gens ont été
contaminés au niveau des ses achats
soldés ou dans des soins chroniques et
donc il ya toute cette espèce d'amalgamé
qui fait qu'actuellement l'état de la
situation à marjah est loin d'être
contrôlé et maîtrisé
parlez moi de la situation dans les
hôpitaux ce que vous en savez bon ya
chez vous un hôpital juif yonne les
autres hôpitaux désignés
quels sont les échos vous savez 1er mai
dès aujourd'hui c'est pas l'espace qui
nous manque c'est vraiment le personnel
était dans les hôpitaux je vous dirai en
ce qui concerne la bonne nouvelle on va
dire c'est que les soins intensifs ne
sont pas débordés par contre le problème
qui a dans les hôpitaux actuellement
c'est qu'on a beaucoup de patients qui
sont des patients
qui ne devrait pas être forcément dans
un hôpital de soins aigus et qui
pourraient et devraient être envoyés
vers des ressources internes hâtif de
réhabilitation de soins transition de
soins chroniques et c'est un peu le
goulot d'étranglement des hôpitaux
auxquels se sont ajoutés des éclosions
convainc et nosocomiales dans certains
hôpitaux de montréal où ça empêche si
vous voulez le flot des patients de
fonctionner et on a aussi le fait qu'il
va falloir encore une fois recommencer à
faire de la médecine que j'appellerais
plus traditionnels parce qu'il ya des
gens qu'il faut continuer de traiter de
soigner de dépister de diagnostiquer
malheureusement la maladie ne s'arrête
pas avec la coved 19 et actuellement on
a fait comme une espèce de pot dans
notre système de santé comme on n'a
jamais fait dans l'histoire du québec
c'est vrai que c'est une situation
particulière et difficile mais la
réalité va falloir qu'à un moment donné
on trouve cette espèce de déquilibre de
jongleurs entre recommencer des
activités qui sont clés est importante
pour la santé de la population et d'un
autre côté s'assurer qu'on traite encore
les patients que 8,19 mais aussi en
essayant de trouver des façons
alternatives de donner des congés
d'envoyer des gens vers d'autres
ressources alternatives et c'est bon pas
un mot sur l'âge parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de confusion dans les
messages envoyés lors des points de
presse à québec
d'abord on disait les 60 ans et plus
restent aidons à la maison après on
disait bombes et les 60 ans et plus vous
pouvez aller travailler si vous êtes
enseignant ou ou aux responsables de
garderies et puis là aujourd'hui
son conte zen ne gardez pas vos
petits-enfants même si j'allais dans
l'éclat est là aujourd'hui on dit bombay
en mod70 en fait dans ce que vous voulez
aller travailler si vous devez aller
travailler ou vous en êtes dans votre
réflexion sur l'âge là bas ça peut
devenir compliqué là c'est pas compliqué
ces statistiques des vhu dépassé l'âge
de 60 ans votre risque de mortalité
augmente de façon significative
on voit que et une augmentation pour les
50 à 59 ans par rapport à toute la
catégorie qui est en bas mais cette
augmentation est relativement faible au
québec quand on regarde al existe elle
est là pour les 50 à 59 mais elles
augmentent de façon très significative
dès qu'on dépasse 60 ans et elle
augmente encore beaucoup plus après 70
ans
évidemment
visuellement on peut toujours essayer de
dire si vous avez 75 ans être un athlète
olympique en super bonne forme et ce que
l'on peut vous comparez etc
il ya tant de comparaison individuelle
mais de façon globale est viré grosso
modo c'est sûr que l'âge est un facteur
de risque dès que de vous dépasser 60
ans votre risque d'avoir des problèmes
augmentent considérablement donc le
message la date a toujours été si depuis
de 60 ans de faire très attention à mon
sens si vous avez plus de 60 ans est
encore de faire très attention
on peut bien sûr individuellement je
tirais discuter avec des autorités
sanitaires de votre médecin etc
de quel est votre rythme et il ya aussi
il faut pas oublier la décision
individuelle de chacun vous pourriez
être des grands-parents de 65 ans en
pleine forme qui vont se dire nous
finalement si dans certaines
circonstances on a été isolé on est en
santé on n'a pas de facteur de risque
on aimerait voir nos petits-enfants pas
trop près mais on aimerait s'approcher
d'eux peut-être pour vous quelques c'est
la fête d'un des petits-enfants etc
donc il peut y avoir des décisions qui
individuellement par se prend maintenant
collectivement c'est sûr que quand on
dit aux gens d'un côté vous devez pas
être en contact avec vos petits enfants
puis maintenant aller travailler en
garderie écouter puis c'est difficile
aux simpson en garderie temps vous avez
des enfants d'âge préscolaire de leur
expliquer la distanciation social
l'interaction entre enfants c'est pas
évident ok mais vous prenez la prudence
pas en même temps si on dit que d'un
côté on peut aller travailler de l'autre
on peut pas garder les gens peuvent pas
comprendre des messages incohérent non
plus je comprends ce que vous dites
statistiquement et on l'a dit on a vu le
tableau pendant que vous parliez de tous
les décès au québec à 6,5 pour cent des
décès qui était âgée entre souder des
gens qui est âgée entre 60 et 69 ans ça
ces statistiques donc le risque de
verizon est plus élevé mais là c'est une
question de gestion du risque je veux je
vous posais une question sur les tests
la question numéro deux du public ne
serait-il pas possible d'inventer une
bandelette sur laquelle on pourrait
mettre une goutte de sang comme pour le
diabète il recevoir le diagnostic
instantanément à la maison
oui alors il les compagnies qui ont fait
ça mais savons pas grand chose alors
c'est pas qu'on n'a pas essayé mais
éventuellement ça arrivera peut-être un
jour mais pour l'instant c'est pas dans
ce n'est pas dans le tableau
bon qu'est ce qui influence le facteur r
vous demande monsieur bélanger la nature
du virus
les asymptomatiques l'environnement la
région quand on parle 10h01 à ce moment
là on parle du facteur de transmission
bah c'est souvent d'abord et avant tout
la nature du virus parce que c'est là la
capacité du virus à se transmettre à
d'autres c'est la façon dont il va se
transmettent la rougeole ça se transmet
énormément c'est un facteur 02 15
la varicelle ça se transmet beaucoup ça
c'est un facteur 0 7 8 9 et puis la
grippe ont dit à peu près avoir trois
îles qu'ovide initialement disait autour
de 2.3 mais là je veux pas rentrer dans
des statistiques complexe on disait oui
mais ça peut être entre eux 1.9 et 4 et
c'est ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que
probablement c'est plus que 2 points 3
en tout cas c'est peut-être autour de 3
c'est peut-être troupe de 4 et puis il
ya des facteurs aussi encore une fois
qui vont influencer sa donc la densité
de la population la proximité entre les
deux les uns des autres la charge virale
initiales de certains la capacité
d'avoir l'équipement de protection
adéquat donc un ensemble de facteurs qui
vont déterminer si oui ou non votre
heure 0 et très bas ou très évoqué
quelques secondes docteur florence mano
nobert 5 1 5 1 vous demandez ce que je
vais pouvoir donner un câlin à mon
éducatrice lorsque je vais retourner à
la garderie je crains votre réponse je
vous dirais il va falloir se sont un cas
la distance mais ça dépend aussi de la
limite de l'âge et de la santé
d'éducatrice encore une fois c'est
difficile
si vous avez une jeune femme dans la
vingtaine qui est en pleine forme
physique sans donner un câlin mais je
veux dire dire un gros bonjour ce serait
adéquat élevé finalement mais il va
falloir aussi faire attention à leur
apprendre à florence que on vit dans un
monde un peu différent d'il ya quelques
mois pour pour quelques tas probablement
merci dr weiss bonne soirée à vous mais
ces bonnes soirées à voir